"PeWdS! YoU hAve tO PLaiy MohRe gAEmz!
Bhud PoOdz, I THOhT yOU WEre aH gAEMiNg cHANnNeLLl??''
"CoMe On PewDZ, pLay sOmm GamEz, MaN."
"WhY hAVen'tchU pLaiYed Sudoku aLLrEaEdy?"
PLAY MORE GAMES!
I WANNA SEE MORE GAMES! PlEAsE! PLAY MORE GaMeSz PLEASE!!
*unintelligible gibberish*
Okay fine!(finally)
I'll play games
I'll play the best goddamn game there is in the entire universe. (oh?whichgameisthat?)
I'm talking, of course, about..
I'm talking of course ABOUT...
I'M TALKING OF COURSE A B O U T
~Ga-ru-za Unda Pan-zah Dorimo Tankuda Machi~
Garuzado panzah doreamo tankun damachi
Oh wow!
Look at that everyone!
Fugh!.. Dammit!
Can I play? Here we go.
It's time to kill
all the..
What the hell is tha...*Pedobear intensifies*
"War has changed."
There you go.
A nice and cute anime game (ohhh i miss yandere simulator)
Where no one gets--
Jesus!
Why is this a game?
*Weird ass Laughing*
Oh Finally a good game everyone.
Oh god
I'm stuck. I'm stuck.
Repair
There you go,
[REKT]
Oh my god is that the Communist sign?
Am I Russian?
Am I USSR?
Oh my god cue the Russian anthem
FIREEE!!
For our country!
You Filthy capitalist anime scumbags
*mother russia intensifies*
Just gotta watch out for bombs and stuff.
Oh..no no no no no no
DAAMMIT
Let's do a shortcut (oh.. GrEAt)
No! Oh no!
I hAve tHE POweR oF GOd
and aNImey On My sIDe!
cOme On mEMe!
No no no no NO
*SCREAMS LIKE AN AUTISTIC CHILD ONCE AGAIN*
War-
-War never changes.
Finally a game that doesn't undermine the terror of WAR
That doesn't glor-
-glorify the horrible things that goes on in battle.
Finally a game with realistic teddy bears.
That you can shoot for extra points
War Has changed
*Vietnam flashbacks*(oh god no)
Wait, who's this?
We're playing as a slav?
An anime slav?
Really?
They're wearing tracksuits
The slavs are here!
CYKA BLYAT!
Yeah!! Hahaha
Wonder if there's any Swedish tanks.
Oh, that's right. We are a bunch of pussies.
*laugh*
*animu raping continues*
Yjaaaooooooowww!!!
Ahhrn nidd skrrt! Oh my gaaaawd! Here it comes!
AAAAAAH
Man, you know this game really makes you think
If war was just filled with anime girls, well, then
then war wouldn't even be that bad.
Oh, those are the Germans?
Am I the Germans?
I think I am.
Great.
Fantastic. Cue the German anthem please
Hail....
REKT. Subtitles by Adamcio Samcio. :D